Victoria, you're next.
What's your question?
Oh, hi!
Hi, Victoria.
Cute jacket.
Question's up.
Yeah, sure, hit it.
So, to make it brief, I need help asking
for a raise for my boss.
Yes, so I've been working
with Settepani Bakery & Restaurant.
So, the restaurant and bakery, Harlem and Brooklyn,
for a while now.
I'm basically like family.
I mean, I've known the family for a really long time.
Actually, the daughter and I were choir together.
And so, yeah, I started working in the restaurant,
and then now I, kind of, am a jack of all trades
behind the scenes,
and yeah, I just feel like it's almost the time.
It's just been that pink elephant in the room, and yeah.
How long have you worked there?
So officially, since 2018,
but I like, through college would help them
in the restaurant and in the back end of things,
but more on the marketing side since 2018.
And when you started-
(audience laughing)
Am I in an interview now?
You worked on their social media
and content strategies.
Correct?
Yeah.
Now, I think I understand
that when you came in to now,
their social media footprint has doubled.
Is that not true?
It's definitely grown a lot. Yeah.
(Victoria laughing)
Well, that's important.
We can talk metrics but it'll bore everyone.
(Victoria laughing)
So we need to figure out how to get your bakery
to give you a little more dough, is what we need to do.
(audience laughing)
Yes.
I agree, Ross.
So, who would you talk to?
I would talk to my boss which would be
Leah Settepani
Leah?
Yeah, do you have Leah's phone number?
Yes, I do.
You know what?
Yeah.
Let's call Leah.
(audience cheering)
Okay.
I would use our flip phones,
but they're gone.
(everyone laughing)
Well, let's see.
Oh, I'm getting word
in my head that she's on the phone right now.
Hello?
Is this for real?
Leah?
Yeah.
Hi, Leah, it's Drew calling,
and I was just speaking with Victoria, and I really hope
that this doesn't kind of catch you off guard
or put you in an awkward position,
but I was so inspired by what Victoria was saying
about working at your company
and we were just looking at the numbers and we were seeing
that due to her content strategy
and social media skills
that she's been able to double your social footprint.
And she really wants to keep working there
and keep the company growing but financially speaking,
she also wants to grow herself,
and so we were wondering if you would be open
to possibly, giving her a raise and compensating her,
so that she can continue to make your company flourish.
Well, first of all, I'd like to say
that Victoria is a real gem.
She's worked with us for a long time.
Settepani would not be Settepani without her support
and her hard work, so, absolutely.
I mean, it's an oversight on my part
for her to even have to come to you.
So, you know, it's something that I would definitely be open
to having a discussion because I do know her worth.
Leah, that's like the perfect answer.
(audience applauding)
Come on!
And I thank her
from the heart 'cause she really is a hard worker.
Well, thank you, Leah, for being open
to being put on the spot like this.
We're all flying by the seat of our pants,
but sometimes it's worth going out there
and fighting for one another-
and trying-
Right!
to help people's dreams come true,
especially when they're working so hard for them.
Yes!
100%.
(audience applauding)
And I wish you the best on your dreams.
You're doing a family run business in tough times
and I'm sure it hasn't been easy.
So, I completely have empathy for that,
and I hope both of you can rise up together.
Yes.
Thank you.
Oh, I love that.
We're gonna come see you.
I'm gonna come see you in Harlem too.
I'm gonna try that bakery.
Okay?
Please do.
Absolutely! Thank you.
Thank you so much, Leah.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
Congrats!
Wow!
(upbeat music)